- Great question.
(bubbling)
If Lily had to babysit a
toddler that'd be carnage.
I imagine her holding it like.
I don't think she'd
know what to do with it.
- If Adam could be part of a
rock band he's play the drums.
- And then I think
she'd get really into it
and she'd like dress up
as like different aliens
and perform for it.
- Lead singer would be Mr. Hendrix.
Lead guitarist would be Headmaster Groff.
And I think it would be
more of like a Guitar Hero,
Rock Band set-up, rather
than an actual band.
And they'd all wear sweatpants
and just jam together.
- If Amy had a superpower
it would definitely
be talking to animals.
Wasps, foxes and lizards.
- If Jackson could change
the rules in swimming
Jackson wouldn't wear y-fronts.
He'd chuck on them shorts.
- If boys didn't exist I don't think Lily
would be too fast.
- If boys didn't exist Amy would thrive.
- I don't think she really is that fast
about whether someone is a boy or a girl.
There are strap-ons.
- Tank Girl.
She's badass and she's
got like shaved hair
and like she's always in fights.
- She'd go out and save the world.
She'd do her thing,
but then she would just
like come home, sit by
herself, snuggle up alone,
and watch ten tile porn.
- If he were suddenly
rich I think he would
move far away as he
could so he could start
a new life where no one knew him.
- If Amy got famous 'round the world
she would promote her
pending cookery/bakery book.
- Top purchases would be
a restaurant business,
specifically seafood
for no apparent reason.
He would be head chef and
it would be fine dining.
The name of that restaurant
would be Hendricks,
Hendricks, Hendricks.
- I think she would rewrite them
and make them very feminist.
Probably a little bit violent.
- If Jackson could get rid of war
I think it'd make him a lot happier.
- If Adam's father was less strict
I think that he would weep uncontrollably
and have some sort of embrace.
- I think if Jackson could
change a moment in history
Jackson would maybe stop putting
so much pressure on Maeve.
- If Lily could spend 24
hours in Amy Gibb's body
I think she'd have a great time.
I think she would really enjoy her boobs,
from a purely scientific,
exploratory standpoint.
I think she would like really sex it up.
- Jackson would be with
Maeve if Otis didn't exist.
- If she was being honest, her dream night
would be watching a film
in between Steve and Maeve,
sat in the middle, with popcorn.
- If Lily was an alien I think
she'd be really, really long,
and like really stringy and maybe
have just like one big eye and antenna.
(bubbling)
She would still sit and read comic books
and try and have sex with things.
- If someone hacked into
Amy's Netflix account
I think she'd just say "Go for it."
I hope you have a lovely time and enjoy
your fave program, sweetie.
She wouldn't care, she's a sharer.
- If Jackson could only watch
documentaries on Netflix
he would watch Street Food.
- I think Blo.
- It would be RuPaul's Drag Race.
- I feel like Lily wouldn't
forget her Netflix password.
She's got it written down
in like multiple locations
so that even if she,
like hidden locations.
What would Adam do if his ex
changed his Netflix password?
He'd probably smoke a joint,
and just go to sleep, I reckon.
- If Netflix didn't exist
Jackson would read a book.
(upbeat music)